i'd love to answer any questions y'all
have about anything
um
uh raise your hands or uh
probably raising your hand is the best
is the best way to do it
yes kai ask your question
all right thanks no thanks again saul
for taking your time and answering
questions i super appreciate it um
my question revolves around a lot of uh
like
things that my colleagues have brought
up which is like dealing with burnout um
especially with like obviously last year
with the coronavirus and even now with
delta variant and like some quarantine
and some measures coming back in i think
a lot of people
um you know the dealing with multiple
things outside of work but it affects
their you know
work and their state of mind so um what
are some
tips
that you have like dealing with burnout
good question and excellent question
maybe the most important question and i
think burnout is one of these things i
don't know how many i'm sure ever all of
everyone here has experienced it in some
way shape or form but it creeps up on
you uh you think you can handle it you
think you can handle it you think you
can handle it until you can't handle it
anymore and then it's usually
too late to address it
there's a couple of things that i have
done preventatively
that i've i have found have been like
almost life-changing for me i meditate
regularly i remember when i was younger
i was intrigued by this idea of
meditation it seemed very mystical and
very powerful and but i remember when i
tried it when i was a teenager i was
like you just sit quietly for four you
know for 10 minutes 20 minutes 30
minutes
how does that work and
you know in hindsight i think i just had
an overactive mind and i couldn't even
imagine what it meant to have a still
mind
fast forward until i'm about five years
ago i'm in my
late 30s at this point
and
i realized that i was approaching a
burnout on a lot of levels you know i
kind of spread myself too then i was
having to do a lot of travel for work i
never enjoyed planes and i was trying to
get claustrophobic on the planes i was
like okay something's going on some
things and that's where i rediscovered
meditation and i think you know it's one
of those things and if possible folks
can mute their uh microphones uh i i
hear some background noise um
it is is that it's a very subtle but
very powerful thing you know i read a
lot of these
gurus who speak about meditation
instilling the mind and our minds
naturally gravitate to the very obvious
things the things that really hit our
senses hard
but our emotional state and our mental
state is a very subtle thing
but what i can guarantee to almost
everyone here is if you do sit down for
that even five or ten minutes but you
know i find it really starts to kick in
at around 30 or 40 minutes um and you
just have faith that it's going to be
good for you
um that it it will be and and there's
even going to be those days where your
mind is wandering and there's noise
outside and you're like oh this isn't a
good meditation even that i find
at after 20 or 30 minutes makes makes a
big big difference also the perspective
that you take to it
i think some some of us myself when i
first tried to do this i was like i
wanted to be the perfect meditator and i
wanted perfect conditions and i'd want
silence and i found myself getting
stressed about the meditation i would
like yell at my kids be quiet i'm
meditating and i realize at some point
that's completely the wrong way to
approach it the way to approach it is uh
to accept everything and to observe
everything and to just try to be still
and to be curious and have a sense of
humor about it like you know and then
when you do it that way uh i find it
very energizing so that's my my biggest
life hack um outside of that you know
just really make sure that you have time
for yourself and your family
you know i just talked about meditation
for some people it might be exercise uh
it might be socializing but you you
can't under invest uh in that that's
something that i've learned uh over the
years uh that we have a culture that
idolizes work
and that's has certain positive aspects
of it uh but
you know we're here to live our lives as
well so that's that's my best best
advice stay socially connected meditate
and make sure you have you have time and
space for yourself it's it's not going
to be a and
you know
someone told me the saying if you don't
have the time to meditate for an hour
you should meditate for two
[Laughter]
and and i also found the other way that
when i meditate
it's always a good use of time like part
of my brain says oh i don't have 10
minutes i don't really you don't have 10
minutes then that's the problem sal if
you don't have 10 minutes
you need to slow down
let's see so many questions i know i'm
giving these super long i think selena
was next
salinas excel
um thank you so much for this session i
um i'm a high school junior at this
moment and um
i'm in a situation where um it's very
hard for me to attend junior year in
person um
and as i live in nyc um there's no
remote option as of now so i'm not
really sure how i should proceed with
this
and since i'm in a small ib school um
the courses in 11th grade and 12th grade
are two-year courses so if i miss junior
year that would be really problematic
because um 12 year 12th grades um
curriculum is based on what i learned in
11th grade
and um i feel that even in the scenario
where my teachers do provide some
guidance from home it would be really
difficult for me to perform well or even
effectively learn the content as i'm
i'm having a different experience from
all my other classmates and i would
really really like to hear your insight
and and advice on this thank you yeah
first of all thanks for asking the
question selena and i and it does sound
like a tough situation um
you know my best advice and as you know
junior year it can be a very important
year um especially you know as you're
trying to think about college and all of
the rest
um
i i don't fully you know know all of all
of what what you might have or not don't
have access to
i do think the good news is
there are avenues outside of the
traditional that could you can still
learn a lot of the material or most of
the material and prove what you know so
that uh colleges and other folks can can
uh can take a serious look at it
many of y'all know that
we've been talking to universities
about schoolhouse university of chicago
famously last year said hey if if you
can certify your knowledge on
schoolhouse and then even better go on
to become a tutor on schoolhouse
we universe chicago are going to take
that very seriously in the college
admissions process
and they actually
out of this public they had a very high
admissions rate for the 40 or so kids
who actually use schoolhouse.world as
one of the one of the main signals that
they used
y'all will hear shortly about mit is
also going to be um
doing doing something similar uh and
we're talking just yesterday i talked to
30 admissions officers at a bunch of
universities saying hey look there's an
interesting signal here you don't want
to force everyone to do it but here's a
mechanism where at least in the subjects
that school house has we can certify
your knowledge and then you can go on to
become tutor
i think that can be a very powerful
potential route
especially because you can leverage
schoolhouse.world and khan academy to
learn the material
and then certify yourself and then
hopefully even become a tutor yourself i
think that will speak very favorably of
how you are leveraging your junior year
uh above and beyond the things
you know all of your math subjects that
i imagine you'd be covering your science
subjects
including you know we just launched
environmental science and we've always
had things like econ on things on khan
academy between khan academy and
schoolhouse i think you can you can do a
lot i think in your humanities
i we want to explore eventually doing
that in schoolhouse.world it's we're not
quite there there's some enrichment
courses where people are starting to
dabble in that but i would recommend you
know take a look at some of the moocs i
think if you're able to go into some of
those moocs and uh do well at in in them
especially if
you could leverage khan academy for your
stem
and schoolhouse for your stem and then
use moocs for some of the other courses
whether it's the history course or your
english course whatever else
um and then also use the time to do to
do uh well on standardized tests on your
sats whatever
i think you're going to have a
i think you're going to have a good
junior year then and i i got to believe
that when you go next year into your
senior year if next year you're going to
apply to college
those colleges are going to take your
circumstances very seriously uh they
definitely look at people who had you
know hard circumstances to deal with and
they say what did you do out of with
those hard circumstances and if you were
able to surprise them uh with what you
were able to do with those hard
circumstances i think you're going to be
fully in the game and i think in some
strange way um having this time might
end up being a gift in some ways because
you're going to explore things that you
might not uh have otherwise had time for
um that's my best advice not not not
fully knowing all of your circumstances
and and i'll add what i had just said
also make sure you don't burn out take
care of yourself uh make sure you don't
lose uh that that piece of the puzzle as
well
um
so sorry about that um thank you for all
the advice so far um i wanted to ask
another question related to this um
because my parents are actually
um considering virtual high school as an
option instead because i'm not really
sure if i can um end up either retaking
junior year or um delaying it
so
i wanted to know if an online high
school diploma would end up putting me
at a disadvantage in college college
admissions
i i'm not an expert here i suspect and i
think there's different online high
schools i'm familiar with a few of them
there's like the you know there's a
stanford online high school which is
very highly reputed and i'm sure there's
others like that um i don't think you're
at a disadvantage at all if you go to
some of these online high schools and on
top of that if you're able to do other
interesting things i think you're going
to be very much in the game so yeah i
wouldn't worry too much about that
thanks selena um let's see i'm gonna go
let's see i i think zoom does it so that
whoever's furthest to the right was the
next person so shivam
your question
hi sal
it's really a dream come true i am
meeting you after so long you need
better dreams
actually i just a little intro like i
have been using khan academy since my
grade six and
i have over one million points on khan
aka
that's an achievement
yeah
so i have just uh just about me like i
have perfected my math through you i
admire you so much
so
the thing is i want to ask is i belong
to a very small town where
there are not good many
good facilities
so uh so how do you think uh would i be
able to do you think is it okay to dream
big like are am i suitable for big
universities and like
students at us have like they do summer
programs and all like that and
i am from
india
bihar and i don't have that much
uh facilities but yeah i am a tutor at
schoolhouse and i really enjoy that
tutoring students but yeah the thing is
i sometimes feel that am i really
disadvantaged
with the students who
do such kind of programs who
have done
internships and all kind
all things like that
yeah it's a great question and you know
the way i think about it and i have
you're right i'm sure you're in a
circumstance where you don't have all
the resources that you would ideally
have
but i you know one of the dreams of
schoolhouse.world is that we can
hopefully reward folks like yourself who
are tutors uh and who are doing really
good at it uh to
to connect them with opportunities that
might not otherwise have been there you
know so i kind of view myself as the
guidance counselor for all of the the
tutor community here and say like how
can i help all of these people get
opportunity because if you really think
about it you know for for college or for
jobs there are these huge complex
processes that you have to usually all
these hoops you have to jump through but
if you boil down to it and i've talked
to other people who hire people as like
you show me someone who can who's a
highly rated tutor on schoolhouse.world
in statistics i'm just picking
statistics could be other subjects
okay why wouldn't you hire that person
that person clearly has analytical
skills that person clearly can
communicate that person clearly has
empathy that like that's
you know here's a little secret in most
jobs in the world that's all if you have
those things you're going to do very
very well everything else you can learn
and so
my hope is that i can
not we collectively not just myself can
figure out ways to connect you to
opportunity uh if
what what what uh grade are you in right
now what class are you in
12th grade you're in 12
yeah okay flying
looking to apply for u.s colleges
yeah well you know i i think uh i i just
listed a few and obviously none of these
colleges are quote easy to get into so
to speak they they um but expect to hear
a few more and i think even the colleges
that aren't part of our initial
consortium so to speak
i think if you
if if you are a very active highly
reputed tutor on schoolhouse.world um
we through the tutor community we want
to be able to help you uh like even if
even if there's a even if there's a
college that doesn't know about
schoolhouse.world if we can leverage
what we know
or our our notoriety to let them know
hey this is not a joke to become a
highly reputed tutor i would take this
very seriously so then i think i think
you would have i think you would have a
fighting chance and you know i will say
even if it does if it does work out
awesome if it doesn't work out i think
you're going to have multiple shots at
goal
so wherever you go to college
there's always you can transfer or even
post college graduate school or your job
i hope over the next three four years
schoolhouse.world being a being a highly
reputed tutor on it becomes a major
thing that a lot of people are going to
index on so that's uh you know that's my
my best advice
okay thank you thanks a lot no thank you
thank you for being a tutor
um
let's see i'm not sure if this is
showing up in order i'm going to go
somewhat um random
just to follow up on shivam's question
okay
i have four sisters in afghanistan who
is going right now and then a lot of
girls you know the situation being
they're really dire i myself i'm working
on facebook here projects here so i've
been really fortunate to have your um
fun academy learning things from you and
then also your platform i was wondering
how can we um
expand that further and then give a
chance for the
like a fighting chance for the girls in
afghanistan or other like countries
where there's where there's war or they
don't have facilities like in india or
elsewhere too how can they do that and
then how can they take advantage of this
situation especially when the schools
when the system do not allow you to go
to schools and like past sixth grade you
cannot even attend if you're a woman so
how can we use your platform and then
have those girls like a fighting chance
if you can maybe kindly answer that yeah
wonderful question um
so yeah it's a big especially given
what's going on now um some of y'all
i've told this story before i the case
in point is very clear there's actually
a young girl named sultana you could do
a google search for her uh me you know
there's a nicholas christophe wrote an
op-ed about her meet sultana the
taliban's worst fear he wrote this four
five three four years ago
but it's it's exactly what you described
even before the current circumstances in
afghanistan where when she entered sixth
grade she wasn't allowed to go to school
her brothers were
and then she luckily did have an
internet connection and
she was able to essentially self teach
herself english she found out about khan
academy that became her lifeline by the
time she gets into high school she
decides that she wants to be a physics
researcher a theoretical physicist um
she she lies to her parents to go to
pakistan to take the s.a.t she doesn't
usually well
anyway
long story short
sultana was eventually able to
make it to the u.s and is now
doing quantum computing research at
tufts university and what i always
remind folks is
for every sultana we know about who's
able to do it how many more
tens or hundreds of thousands or
millions might there be and what she had
to do to get there
you know none of us i don't think i
would have been able to do that if i was
given the same set of obstacles so she
had unusual determination unusual
resilience
you know my hope is that
khan academy schoolhouse.world
can be that lifeline now it is
predicated on internet access my
understanding of what's going on on the
ground in places like afghanistan is
that you know fingers crossed they
haven't shut down internet access
so if
if if that's what we can depend on then
we can provide layers on top of that
that can at least give someone a
lifeline and i could imagine you know
sultana went on her journey before
schoolhouse.world existed
but if schoolhouse.world existed she is
someone who i i very easily could
imagine would have been very active in
this community
she would have certified her knowledge
she would have used the community to
learn frankly not just to learn the
subject matter but frankly to learn
the language to learn english
and then
she would have gone on to become a tutor
and uh you know just like chauvin's
question i think she could have then
used that as a signal to people to say
look you know this is someone
interesting that we need we need to make
sure has opportunities so that's my best
answer
you know i i wish
i wish there were things that we we
could do more on the ground and
i i don't know i don't know but um you
know our collective uh avenue here is
you know we can the khan academy can
make more resources but i think
schoolhouse.world can actually be a very
very powerful resource uh for for these
these young girls if they just have an
internet connection um they can become
part of this community and i'm hoping my
dream for schoolhouse.world is it
between it and khan academy can almost
turn into a safety net education system
for the world so that if you are going
to a school with resources awesome use
khan academy to personalize and get even
better and get your schoolhouse for
supplemental tutoring so you don't fall
through the cracks but if you don't have
a great school or if you have no school
at all
khan academy schoolhouse.world the
certification the tutoring um
you you can get to where you want to go
so that's my best um
answer for uh an actual you know very
unfortunate circumstances that the world
the world is in right now thank yourself
for the answer and um could they also
use your han lab high school program to
get admitted and then especially if the
schools are being shut down
yeah so
good question so khan lab high school
some of y'all might know i started the
school con lab school
seven years ago it's now k through 12
there's a high school con lab high
school
i'm always sensitive everything has my
name on it now but people assure me it's
good for branding um
i used to make fun of people who name
things after themselves but it shows you
um but but the uh uh
you know we are exploring doing a
virtual component the original spirit of
the vision of con labs high school is
can we create a model that then can be
replicated and everywhere whether we
replicate it or other people copy
awesome
we are now realizing it there might be
interesting regret creating a virtual
component that leans on khan academy and
schoolhouse.world but could also cert
that could also give people credit um
you know but but i will say going back
to shivam's original question well
because even khan lab school even for
the students who are going there in
person it's a very non-traditional
school it's mastery based kids have the
opportunity incentive to improve their
grades we don't use letter grades we use
a slightly different form of grading but
it's unusual so um there was always the
question of these parents was like are
these kids even going to get into
college
and
what we have found is in the u.s at
least the private schools are very
flexible and are very open to looking at
alternative things especially if they
can make sense of them so that's where i
think the schoolhouse.world
certification tutoring could have a lot
of value and we're seeing more and more
of the public schools uh are also
opening opening their aperture to it
but you're right
if if con lab high school or other
partners we're talking to some colleges
that also might give college credit for
certain types of mastery on khan academy
or schoolhouse.world that also could be
interesting so we we want to continue to
explore that
so uh see next question renee
i'm not sure if i'm going in order but
i'll try to
yeah thank you
sal um and uh hi everyone um at first i
just want to thank you um i used your
account academy many years ago and i was
able to got into a get into a really
good university and then uh get into my
phd degree a program here so i really
just wanna thank you um and then so my
question here is uh how do you deal with
information overload
you know how do you learn something
because every time you search for
something there are thousands of
thousands stuff so so how are you doing
uh you're learning
in this world
it's it's it's it's a great question i
you know i was once i was giving a talk
in spain uh two years ago and
the
it was the most poetic introduction i
had ever gotten but part of the
introduction
was this notion that
the irony is when there's a flood that's
when actually people oftentimes die of
dehydration or experience dehydration
when there's a flood and the introducer
he made the analogy is that the same
thing is happening in information today
there's a flood of information but we
are still
but not but a lot of it we can't trust
or or or it messes with us um
even the news itself even if we
i know there's a huge issue globally but
especially in the us about news being
polarized and we're all in our own
bubble
but even even if you assume the news is
not biased although everything has some
kind of a bias even if you assume it's
not biased the news by its very nature
is taking a world of seven or eight
billion people and telling you the seven
worst things that happened that day
like
like our brains aren't good at
processing that
you know i wish they could tell us the
because the same day that those seven
horrible things are happening there's
probably seven hundred thousand
beautiful things that happened that
weren't quote newsworthy and so it
messes with your head it messes with
your brain
so what i would say is protect yourself
from it i i think future
future health professionals are going to
realize that exposing yourself to this
type of thing can become really harmful
that doesn't mean you know put your head
in the sand i i read the news but i
really do try to be conscientious of
like look i can go to a website and i
can read a few headlines i got the
essence of the news if i were to go and
go on you know these 24-hour channels or
on social media i'm going to start
getting all of these other things that
are all designed frankly to get me
worked up
and i don't want to be worked up
so i'm going to go do my work put one
foot in front of the other live my life
meditate
you know sometimes when i am
experiencing the information overload
and it might not become not it might not
be from social media or from work from
from from the news it might be from work
i'm constantly getting emails in i'm
constantly people are slacking me people
are this you know there's 910 decisions
that are coming to my desk every day um
and i can feel it i become more
sensitive to saying hey sal you're
feeling kind of off you're you're you're
not present right now then i just try to
stop what i'm doing and even do a
10-minute meditation just sit quietly or
go for a walk um
i find is a great way to reset and then
on top of that you know make sure you're
getting exercise make sure you're eating
well drinking a lot of water and
sleeping well i i do this stuff
religiously um
so so that that's my best advice for the
information overload or when you're
feeling angsty about the world
you know just find a place of stillness
a place of quiet and and try to be
careful on how much that stuff sucks you
in and i i've been sucked in you know
some of the news that's going on in the
world like oh we should watch it i watch
it and it's like you can't turn it off
and like an hour goes late and you're
like i don't feel better right now
and i learned the important news within
the first two minutes the rest of the 58
minutes just made me feel kind of not so
good so let me let me go do something
else that best and in terms of the
question of how do i learn
um
i i
i'm constantly just asking questions
so i'm actually about to make a middle
school science video on the atmosphere
and some some people on my team sent me
some
some standards that we need to cover and
they're pretty basic uh but i'm like
okay what makes this interesting and i'm
like okay
uh
let me make sure that i can help explain
you know where does officially where
does the atmosphere end in space start
now we know it's not it's not like
there's some line where it actually
doesn't it's it's a gradation but people
have the karman line and they've defined
it as roughly 60 something miles and
okay what are the you know
the lowest satellites okay those you
know it's about 100 miles uh and i just
keep asking these questions of like okay
if something's in low earth orbit
because it's still going to have some
atmosphere still going to run into a few
nitrogen
and oxygen molecules every now and then
it's going to slowly slow down and
slowly come back to earth
how long do they last so for me it's
just asking these these these fun
questions um
over and over again and and having that
sense of curiosity about it and then
once i'm really jazzed about whatever
i'm about to do then i just press record
and go uh but you know that's something
pretty simple if something is more
esoteric i like to talk to people about
it i'll call up friends uh
another thing i like to do when
something is is dense or i'm trying to
conceptually get it
read it one day and say okay my brain
will process it you i kind of delegate
it to my brain and my mind and i'm like
by tomorrow my mind will have insights
about it don't worry about it conscious
sal subconscious cell has it covered and
it's amazing uh that it works but it
does i remember in in college when i
would take these theoretical math
classes sometimes you look at the
problem sets
and you're like i don't i can't make
sense of any of this but you do it you
at least try every problem
you close the book go to sleep in the
morning i can do like 80 of them i've
done the same thing on tests where i'm
taking this test you know these really
deep theoretical math classes and
you see four or five questions and
you're like i don't know let me just
think about it but then i kind of get
into a meditative place and in about 20
minutes i'm like oh my subconscious is
starting to give me the answers i'm like
it's amazing what the subconscious can
do uh so anyway that's that's other
advice we're almost out of time let me
see i'm sorry i couldn't get i'm giving
you these long-winded um
answers uh let's see maybe salil
no salic salic
solid k
hello sal it's great to meet you i am 12
years old and
currently being homeschooled and i'm
also ahead of the of my class if i was
if i was studying school
so
i've been using the khan academy
platform since one year and i have about
1.5 million energy points on it and then
go ahead sorry i interrupted you
i'm sorry it's okay uh and i finished
grade eight grade five i have rise grade
five and grade six six and finished
grade 7 and grade 8
and also finish all the javascript on
the khan academy platform
and
now learning html and
looking forward to learning all the
other programming languages available on
the khan academy platform so
actually i know uh it's a good it has a
very good future ahead in programming so
can you advise me
and uh
advise me in this
since i'm from pakistan and
it's past midnight here i'll take
advantage and ask two questions
um if you don't mind so
my second question is i have a great
taste in gaming so uh
can i have can i build a future out of
it
yeah well first of all um solik i have i
have no no no doubt i mean don't get
over confident but i have no doubt that
you're going to do very well um and i'll
make my plug because i i have you now
before anyone else is asking for
donations when you become a billionaire
founder of a gaming company remember how
much of that was due to khan academy um
and you know ten percent maybe okay i'm
kidding um
uh but
i don't think i will thank you my whole
life okay
look i'm only half joking um but but
uh to your point yeah look you you if if
you love coding and you're the exact
same age as my oldest son um y'all will
probably get along he's also really into
coding and all of the rest um keep keep
doing it and i would say keep building
things uh keep progressing academically
and i have no doubt that and your
question about gaming yeah i only think
that's only going to become a bigger and
bigger industry both in the gaming
industry in particular and look you look
at companies like minecraft and roblox
stuff i mean these are massive things
and in the next 10 or 15 years there's
going to be things that are
a whole order of magnitude even bigger
so there's i think there's unlimited uh
work to be done there and also i think
every other industry is thinking about
how do they
uh automate and leverage technology more
and then how do they gamify more you
know something we think a lot about khan
academy is how do we make better game
mechanics so that we can uh you know
addict the sonics of the world into
learning and
all of this so yeah you're you're gonna
keep keep doing what you're doing uh
remembering my answers to the other one
don't burn out don't put too much
pressure on yourself uh make sure you
you know if you can
when i when when my children were first
born i was a little bit of a tiger dad
thinking oh if if they can master their
their subject matter if they can build
some of these hard skills they're going
to be fine and there is some truth to
that obviously every parent wants their
children to
be able to to be able to support
themselves support their family have a
healthy productive life but as i've
grown
i realize yes that's important but the
most important thing is having kind of a
mental emotional resilience and that's
where my first and my first advice to
kai around the meditation and making
time for yourself and having a good
social network incredibly incredibly
important if you have the combination of
those two things
you really are going to be unstoppable
because everyone's journey is going to
have some high points and you're gonna
get you're gonna you know i have more
low points than
than y'all might imagine and i've
definitely had them over my over my life
but it's that ability to kind of detach
yourself from your ego sometimes to not
get too worked up about some things have
some have some tools at your disposal to
meditate uh to
to exercise to whatever it is uh for
some folks it might be religion uh but
it gives it takes you into that
meditative place i think that'll make
you incredibly resilient so if you've
got the skills and you've got the
resilience you're going to be you're
going to be unstoppable so that's my
best best advice there maybe time for
one where i know we're over but i'm
having a good time uh
daisy i'm somewhat randomly picking
hi sal
um so first i just want to say thank you
for all that you have done to enrich the
educational experiences of learners to
khan academy and now schoolhouse so i
myself um i'm a teeter at school house
and i'm sort of constantly
looking for ways uh that i can more
effectively um like present uh or teach
concepts and so i'm sort of just
wondering do you have any tutoring
strategies or tips that you like to use
and has there perhaps been someone like
a teacher whose teaching style you
really admire and who has been an
inspiration to you as an educator thanks
oh a good question and you know
not that i fully figured out i think
there's two modes that i get into uh one
is a
the mode the explaining mode and that's
the one that many of y'all might be
familiar with on khan academy and when
i'm in explaining mode that's where
i try not to script it i try not to over
plan it i do try to make sure that i am
excited about what i'm about to do
because i always tell anyone teaching if
you're not excited about it there's no
way that your students are going to be
excited about it i also try to not be
stressed about it because stress humans
are very good at sensing stress in other
people and for most learners it's
already a slightly stressful experience
or maybe a very stressful experience and
then if the teacher is stressed that's
only going to make the student even more
stressed so i like to
you know even though you don't see my
faces on khan academy videos i actually
do force myself to smile no matter what
happened my car might have gotten towed
whatever else but i'll force myself to
smile uh before making the video i force
myself to just kind of relax if i'm not
relaxed i will take a little bit of a
one minute two minute breather just get
get into a good place because it's gonna
show up and then really try to focus on
the intuition and the ahas and and let
your personality shine as much as
whatever your personality is i think
when you show that authenticity you
really connect and then the you know
what i imagine who i'm speaking to i
really just try to speak to almost like
a younger not even a younger just a
version of myself that just has not
learned this material yet but i try to
respect that okay they are also curious
they also want to connect the dots i
don't try to talk down to them or i
don't try to talk above them so that's
that now the other mode is the school
the schoolhouse.world mode when you're
actually with people like we are now uh
tutoring
that's where i keep trying to remind
myself the more that i can be a question
ask her and it can be directed questions
the better uh and
i've had trouble sometimes with awkward
silence like even at dinner parties i'm
always the guy that like when there's
like three seconds of awkward silence
i'm trying to fill it in somehow
who saw the game last night you know i
one of my things that i need to work on
is is being more comfortable with that
awkward silence and also as a when
you're tutoring folks you ask a question
people might not have an answer
immediately but make sure they have some
space to do it or give them context like
the message board where it's like hey
everyone put what you think that might
feel a little bit safer if someone's a
little bit more introverted i think try
to pull people out of the screen as much
as possible in schoolhouse.world make
them feel safe but say hey you know call
on them a little bit you know what do
you think what how would you approach
this problem but i think the more that
you can make them do the work and you
are
you're pulling it out of them i think
that's going to be a really good
experience and you just bring this you
know joy and energy to it um
i i think it's going to be quite quite
wonderful
thank you so much
all right all right i i this this is
super okay well i'll do i'll do two more
quick questions i'll do two questions
and i will go to
let's go to
uh
jose and sarah i'm apologies to everyone
else apologies everyone jose and then
sarah
hi sal um my name is jose obviously um
i'm 13 i'm a sophomore and an
international student
um so first i i just i just really
appreciate you taking the time to
um help us you know um by giving us this
opportunity um now
my question is for students who
want to advance um
advance more than what their school
might be offering what the school
teaches the school curriculum
and for me specifically math and science
um
uh
for students who have already taken the
time to you know apart from you know
doing the school assignments and
preparing for standardized tests and all
of that
um
also taking the opportunity to um
participate in extracurricular uh say
online
activities such as khan academy such as
schoolhouse
for me it's khan academy and aops
in order to advance their knowledge um
for math and science
how they might be able to communicate to
um schools as well as other institute
institutions uh the knowledge that
they've gathered on their own um using
you know non-accredited um institutions
and you've talked a little bit about
this in some of your interviews about
how ideally educational institutions
would be independent from accreditation
because that allows mastery learning to
take place instead of just um
um that you know that grade mindset i
have um i have to get 100 i have to get
an a right just um to actually take to
line the time to learn those concepts um
how how do you communicate that to
teachers
yeah you know the good thing so there's
two things one is i think if any of
y'all
there are ways to do it even without any
kind of extra systemic support i
remember when i was in high school i was
going through a similar i was taking
courses that i i was born and raised in
new orleans so i was taking courses at
the university of new orleans when i was
in high school which back then was
actually a fairly non-standard thing to
do and so actually at first i remember
them not even letting me take the
courses because i wanted to take them
when i was you're roughly your age and
they're like we don't do that and i
remember i kept going to there i'm
saying like what do i need to do to let
you take the court and you'd be
surprised if you're persistent enough
people will eventually let you and then
i remember i wanted to take more courses
and then they wouldn't let me because
there's some policy and then i said
well see how i do so i think you can
always keep pushing keep pushing the
envelope there uh never never doubt the
power of that the good thing is some of
these ideas are a lot more mainstream
now and you know just the very fact that
you're thinking about this at age 13 is
a sorry my kids are screaming in the
other room um
that just the fact that you're you're
you're thinking about this at age 13 i
it's gonna it's it
i wouldn't worry first of all uh but
we're working on it for you too so if
you go on
maybe you already if you tutor on
schoolhouse.world and build a good a
strong reputation as i said you know
already two uh very
strong universities uh
are are interested in looking at
schoolhouse.world tutors uchicago and
mit
um
and i talked to 30 others yesterday by
the time you are actually going to
college i suspect we're going to have 50
or 100 of them that will take a serious
look at it i'm also working with some
scholarships i talked to a very
prestigious scholarship yesterday
don't be surprised if in the next two
three months schoolhouse.world becoming
a highly reputed tutor on
schoolhouse.world
puts you kind of at the front of the
line for some of these really really
good scholarships i'm also going to be
talking to employers some of the
employers that i think many of y'all
would love to work at
where hey if someone is a a great tutor
highly reputed tutor on
schoolhouse.world why wouldn't you give
them an internship um
and and you know we'll go back to my
example if someone can tutor algebra
calculus statistics biology
whatever it might be by that point we
should hopefully have tutoring in other
subjects in english and in in in history
and whatever else by then uh why not why
not um hire those folks so the good
thing is you're 13. so by that point
i will have done more of the homework
and and you will have more opportunities
than you'll know what to deal with but
don't be complacent keep working and
meditate
thank you
sarah take us home
hi sal um
you have been my role model ever since
even i used your platform even before
there was even just your youtube videos
even and now i'm a phd student
and i've shared
those salcon videos to almost everyone
that i've met across my journey so i'm
in all of your work um and i actually
started tutoring on my own because i'm
motivated by you and then i saw a school
schoolhouse style world i started a
similar initiative in my in my
university uh
inspired again inspired by and i was
like oh he has something similar um so i
just wanted to say thank you for all
that you do um and it it really brings
um a lot of joy to everyone learning one
of the things that i wanted to talk to
you about was
the motto is you can learn anything
anywhere so one of the you hit on this
previously as well the issue is what
about these areas where there isn't
internet access that even in the united
states we have these low-income areas
now have you ever considered
partnering with these internet providers
maybe creating um i know comcast has the
uh internet essentials program um and
other companies that also have uh these
internet access programs and
might benefit i mean
how how do you plan on overcoming this
obstacle yeah great question and
something that you know we can't we
constantly discuss at khan academy over
the years
the
the the good if there is if there is a
silver lining of the pandemic is it it's
put a bigger spotlight on this issue
than i've ever seen
and we know for the first time
governments and industry and
philanthropists around the world are
more serious about it than they've ever
been
in the u.s this latest infrastructure
around has 60-something billion dollars
to close the digital divide which should
go a long way now that's just the u.s
what about the rest of the world
we the simplest is yes we'll we want to
we're we are relatively small
organization we're not going to be the
people who could put fiber in the ground
or we have lobbyists in dc we can't do
that kind of we actually we're not even
allowed to lobby in dc it's a
not-for-profit but we're not going to be
the organization that does that puts
fiber in the ground or put satellites in
the air but i think the existence of
khan academy in schoolhouse.world i
think only highlights the importance of
giving access and access isn't just
about academics it's even just about
economic empowerment and even social
well-being to some degree as long as you
can stay off of the really bad stuff um
but we we uh so so we try to do what we
can actually comcast has been one of our
long time partners i had a conversation
with the spacex folks working on
starlink they're indeed
if that works out that's great um that
you know we can get more internet to
more of the world
so yes
that's something that is definitely
something we think about we have been
signatories to things with common sense
media to try to close the the digital
divide and now they talk about the
homework gap which is really the digital
divide at home
uh but we yes we try to do whatever we
can now the good news is it it isn't
happening fast enough for any of us all
of us would love that five years ago
there should have been no digital buy 10
years ago there still is one but if you
look at it historically compared to
almost any other technology
ramp up you know the refrigerator
television
it's quite fast so i do try to
think about let's build for where the
world is going
so i believe in 10 years you know the
type of internet access and the type of
devices that are currently you know
fancy i think are going to be fairly
mainstream in 10 years uh and then if
khan academy and schoolhouse.world can
sit on top of those then
probably not everyone's going to access
and in fact probably the biggest barrier
for access won't be that it'll be like
governments it'll be like the taliban
it'll be government you know it'll be
stuff like that war that that disrupts
people but economically it should be
hopefully feasible so fingers crossed uh
but we just got to keep pushing on that
we could one of the things i was
thinking about maybe creating like these
huh like there's a lot of schools well
earlier in the pan maybe there's
libraries closed or schools closed maybe
creating these hubs of this i don't know
again that branding of con like these
con hubs are like that provide internet
access in these low-income areas which
obviously will have com you know khan
academy in the schoolhouse world
on in the computers or whatever but some
kind of access to these low-income areas
exactly 100 right you know we've had
ideas and i've talked to people
this actually is what libraries of the
future should be i mean
physical books have you know that's good
but people need a hub
there's that i've had conversations with
major retailers i was just like why
don't you take that back right corner of
your store that no one goes to right now
turn it into a learning lab yes and by
the way parents will come drop their
kids off there for half an hour while
they can learn from khan academy in
schoolhouse.world and their parents are
gonna buy something they're gonna
they're gonna do their shopping and then
and you're giving them childcare
actually too and then you could pick up
their kids and their kids would have
learned so
yeah open to all ideas museums libraries
even big box retail um and then and in
really you know rural places or
developing parts of the world you could
manage a shipping container with a
internet connection to us to starlink um
put a couple of low-cost devices in
there hire someone from the village who
can just make sure that nothing shady
happens um and go you have a school in a
box so to speak so
let's work
like some kind of like to go school yeah
exactly that's right so so yeah that's i
mean it goes back to that what i said
earlier
there's two scenarios you have a school
which hopefully you do and then
hopefully khan academy and
schoolhouse.world can make it even more
personalized even better but we also
want to be the the world's
uh education safety net so that no one
has nothing and actually the safety
net's pretty darn good uh so yeah let's
figure it out it's not gonna be solved
tomorrow but it's it's an admirable goal
to keep keep pushing on so i will stop
great minds we'll figure it out yes yes
and congratulations to people just as i
just as i told um
salic you know to be a donor one day
either depending if you go to industry
academia be a donor one day or you know
when you get the nobel prize i just want
a small mention um if not for khan
academy you know we might not have cured
this disease but don't you worry so i'm
donating to you already don't you oh
very good
with my amazing stipend
i feel somewhat guilty about from from
from that
but later on when you're making the big
money then you should um but well thanks
everyone the good thing is this is a
series we're going to be doing this
again next week so uh everyone i'm
trying to kind of remember the names and
the faces of people who i did not get to
uh and everyone else keep me honest on
uh vinay
uh christine
uh jose a
uh evelyn
um maeve
athena uh and colonel we didn't get to
you and obviously everyone else can ask
questions too so i look forward to
hopefully getting to all of your
questions uh next week see you then this
was a lot of fun thanks everybody see
you next week thanks thank you so much
thank you thank you
were you the one that joined and i let
people in or was this hell
okay uh
you're gonna do this again or should we
make a note
uh sal next time is it possible to i
guess give someone cause to let people
in
oh yeah i do that just tell me how to do
it yeah because i got like 10 challenger
requesting like they're waiting for them
to enjoy the reading and i don't have
admin access
but it's okay
i just don't want to leave that's all
oh yeah you're still part of the
recording i'm reading all the i'm really
i'm reading all of the messages before
oh yeah there's a ton i think you can
download them too somewhere
actually if one of y'all can download
them yeah
yeah if you uh the three dots at the
bottom yeah same chat i think that
submits as a txt file
showing to find it
all right thanks everyone see y'all
bye
bye everyone